So why should you use IndexedDB over Web SQL? Well,
the good side is that IndexedDB is supported in Chrome, including
Chrome for Android, as well as Firefox, IE, and Opera. The
downside is that, it's not supported in the old Android browser
or in Safari. So, there are going to be a bunch
of mobile users out there that don't have IDB support for
a while. Of course, there are a bunch of mobile users
out there that aren't going to have Web SQL support either.
So what's a web developer to do? Well in general,
I like to recommend trying to do the right thing, but
pragmatically making it work in tough situations. The answer here
is write to IndexedDB, but use a polyfill so it will
work on Web SQL browsers. A good polyfill to use
is the IndexedDB shim. There's a link down in the instructor
notes. Writing your code this way, you can write good
IndexedDB code, but it'll still work on Safari, or other browsers
that don't yet support IndexedDB.